de mon ministère un ministère de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé ça veut dire que
c'est bien à la fois le gouvernement les
territoires et les mers sont les
premiers réparateurs des mots parce que
ce sont les premières portes d'entrée
ils l'ont très bien exprimé ce matin je
le sais en tant qu'il est donc c'est
bien avec eux et la crise sanitaire a
montré à quel point leur implication a
été nécessaire et profession de santé le
et est important dans le nom de ce
ministère parce que comme l'exprimé
comme long exprimait les maires les
maisons de santé qui sont construites
elles ne fonctionnent que lorsqu'elles
sont co-construites avec les
professionnels et l'appui des élus
[Musique]